so I just started shooting it that way
like well I'm gonna make a feature I'm
gonna make a 16 millimeter feature black
and white and it'll be cool I ended up
working for like three years on this
movie and this was going to be my
feature and I was like I was financing
it from working at a video store so what
means was like I would like to get like
200 or so and then we'd go off and shoot
for the weekend the I I we had I didn't
have I had so much so little money that
I couldn't even process this footage all
right that I was saying that's way too
expensive all right so eventually I
ended up after like about about three
years I ended up like starting
processing some of the footage and
starting seeing exactly what I had and
guess what what I did not have at home
I was able to look at it in a realistic
way after being horribly depressed for a
little bit but only a short little bit
was the fact that well this was my film
school all right and this was the best
film School a person could possibly have
I mean I actually instead of like going
to school and paying a ton of money to
be allowed to use some of their crappy
equipment all right I actually went out
and actually tried to make make a
feature film